Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Spider-Man
Across the Spider-Verse was just released and
in place of a traditional post-credit scene they
just released the first teaser for Spider-Man
beyond the spider-verse which is part 2 of the
story like Avengers Infinity War Avengers end
game style they've already revealed what's going
on with the movie so we'll break it all down if
you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos and careful
for spoilers for beyond the spider-verse if you
haven't seen the movie yet we need to talk about
everything that happens just because it does set
up directly what's happening at the beginning of
beyond the spider verse but at the end of the
movie Miles Morales uses what they're calling
the get home device which is a version of the
master Weaver from the spider-verse comics in
the Madame web character put together basically
to get back to his universe but it detects the
DNA of the spider that bit him from Earth 42
which apparently mutated his body so now he has
part Earth 42 DNA and sends him there instead
we learned that the spot tested Kingpin super
collider before the events of the first movie
by yoinking the radioactive spider from Earth
42 and that spider is shown in his flashback
scene was about to bite Earth 42 miles instead
they explained that there was never supposed to
be a Peter Parker Spider-Man to have existed on
Earth 42 Earth 42 miles was always supposed
to be the one and only Spider-Man of that
Earth and because the spider bit ultimate Miles
Morales instead turning him into a version of
Spider-Man it prevented any Earth 42 Spider-Man
from existing which turned that into more of a
Back to the Future 2 version of itself like super
dark version evil corporations take over although
you could call that a version of rr2 like evil
corporations are all over the place but on Earth
42 in the movie chiefly among them the Sinister
Six cartel which Jay Jonah Jameson on that Earth
is yelling about he's talking about a curfew
that's happening because they're having a Turf War
that version of this Sinister Six was a bunch
of the original characters from the comics that
controlled large corporations it was Electronics
as an electro felt like Electro vulture Corp a
sandman Rolex watch you see here scorpo for
Scorpion Dr octopus's company was just called
OCT 8 in RR for Rhino casinos more on them in a
second because I do think that they will figure
into the plot of beyond the spider verse But
ultimately these events led to the death of
Earth 42 Miles Morales father instead of his uncle
Aaron Davis the original version of the prowler on
that Earth and as a result Earth 42 miles goes
dark and becomes the next version of the prowler
because his uncle Aaron Davis is a little bit
darker part of the idea being that his father
wasn't there to lead him down a better path than
his uncle did so when ultimate Miles Morales is
captured by them at the end of the movie it's
meant to be a dark Twist on Miles meeting Peter
B Parker in the first movie tying him up to the
punching bag and even though it seems like his
pleas with Earth 42 miles are falling on deaf ears
and he'll try to Revenge kill miles blaming him
him for the death of his father just like Peter
B Parker escaped I think they'll have a Twist on
that where it seems like miles is about to escape
using his spider sting shocker ability right as
the movie's about to end in that final scene with
him you see his finger reaching down to the chains
with it charging up getting ready to escape while
this is happening Gwen assembles her own team
paying off her line from earlier at the movie at
the beginning about never finding the right band
to be in the team is meant to be the right band
here is everyone from the first movie in addition
to spider Punk whose comeback Spider-Man India
and spider bite who all end the movie entering
the portal to Earth 42 to rescue miles so beyond
the spiderverse is meant to pick up immediately
after these moments like literally right as he's
escaping the punching bag this miles versus Earth
42 miles and I'd say he's gonna fight Aaron Davis
too this version of Aaron Davis but I think the
whole vibe of that scene of him hanging him up on
the punching bag was just preparing him for Miles
so that Miles could get his revenge for the death
of his father like he Chuckles I'm not the prowler
because miles is now and this is his turn to
get revenge ultimate Miles Morales had just
put the rest of the pieces together for them
like he explains everything that happened like
I'm From Another Earth the spider bit me it was
supposed to bite someone else on this Earth and
Earth 42 miles is putting the pieces together
in his head like oh it's your fault you're the
person who took this from my Earth you're the
reason my father is dead even though it was the
spot who was responsible for all that Miles gets
blamed for pretty much everything in the movie by
every different character like Spider-Man 2099
blames him for everything the spot blames him
for everything even though technically this is
all the spot's fault their fight will probably
end in some kind of draw or them almost killing
miles like Earth 42 miles is supposed to be just
as capable as Spider-Man Miles so they're meant to
be relatively evenly matched but he's also facing
Aaron Davis Prowler here too so early Theory miles
barely fights them to a standstill long enough for
spider Gwen and her team to reach him and save him
you can let me know in the comments though if you
think that ultimate miles will find a way to help
Earth 40 32 miles and he'll eventually decide to
become a hero and fight his Earth's version of the
Sinister Six in the form of that cartel that would
be the more hopeful ending and I think that's
what they want to go with at the end of beyond
the spider verse at least for Earth 42 miles that
was what his whole speech was with his version of
Aaron Davis like my uncle became the prowler but
he wanted to be good but he never thought that he
could be good you can totally be that person too
so I think he's going to give that same speech
to Earth 42 miles like there's goodness inside
you you can be a good person so the Earth 42
will eventually get the hero that it was meant
to have it'll just be a version of the prowler
who's turned good because he won't have the spider
bite sort of the same way that he inspired Peter B
Parker at the end of the first movie where he went
back to his Earth 616 married his version of Mary
Jane and they had made a Parker like everything on
his Earth was terrible until the end of the movie
miles inspired him he went back and he made
his Earth better spider-gwen's team will be
way more focused on stopping the spot and saving
miles's father you can let me know if you think
will wind up killing one of his parents or
they'll make it in time to save both of them
they really want you to wonder if one of them is
going to survive but here's the thing about the
spot I think the reason why they kept hyping
up the evolution of miles is spider Stinger
shock ability is to show that he can drain the
spot's Dark Matter energy just like he drains
other types of energy it'll just mess miles up
big time absorbing all that dark matter early
theory he also starts bleeding a little from
his armpits just because it messes him up so
bad paying off the jokes about his new suit
in the movie A couple of different characters
repeat that joke about him bleeding from the
armpits in the movie and like Peter B Parker
says they'll build him a new suit at the end
of the movie there was a montage earlier in the
movie about building new suits they're all based
on comic book suits there was even a cape based
suit that he designed which is a reference to the
Spider-Man cape jokes earlier in the first movie
and it's a no on the cape I think it's cool take
that off it's disrespectful Spider-Man
doesn't wear a cape I think this is a
foreign the other big thing that they tease much
earlier in the film too is that Miles leaves his
mother like this is the last time that he sees
her in this movie saying that he promised that
he would come back and he promised that he
would have a nice cake that's not all messed
up so early prediction is that's how they end
beyond the spider verse they stop the spot from
collapsing all of reality Spider-Man 2099 comes
around on him and finally leaves him alone and
they have some shawarma tags seen at the end of
the movie where he comes home to his parents with
an ice cake and introduces them to the rest of
his friends that he mentioned at the beginning
of across the spider verse and they all eat cake
that he brings back with him including spider ham
like it would be funny to see his parents meeting
spider ham it can get weirder he was also trying
to tell his parents his secret identity like he
was about to tell his mother a couple times then
he tells the wrong Earth 42 mother he'll probably
tell his parents that he is Spider-Man at the end
of the movie too the other thing about the spot
in beyond the spider verse is that he's doing
all this a collapsing reality because he thinks
that Miles was responsible for everything or at
least blames him for everything that happened and
he thinks that Miles doesn't take him seriously
miles sounds like he's going to try and talk him
down a little bit in addition to de-powering him
with his Stinger ability but instead of locking
him up for the rest of all time like a normal
supervillain early theory is that Miles wins
him over so he chills out and eventually tries
to help him and just uses power his brains for
good in the future during the comics the spot
was both a villain and a hero so I think they're
just playing on that same idea like he could go
either way they'll end things in a more hopeful
way and the spot will actually start doing some
good and because there were so many live-action
crossovers in across the spider verse I think the
idea is they want to set some of these characters
up for Secret Wars Avengers 6 crossover there were
a lot of smaller crossovers with Tom Holland
Spider-Man during the movie like Doctor Strange
the events of Spider-Man no way home the
nerd on Earth 19999 then with a Toby Maguire
Spider-Man Andrew Garfield Spider-Man scenes
they were kind of crossover scenes but expect
bigger crossovers bigger live-action cameos
things like actual Cameo scenes part of the
idea I think is that during across the
spider-verse one of the reasons why you
didn't see bigger Cameo scenes from all three
of those versions of Spider-Man live action is
because they would not have been cool with what
Spider-Man 2099 was doing with Miles Morales let
me know in the comments though what kind of big
crossovers you want to see like bigger crossovers
with live-action stuff in Spider-Man beyond the
spider-verse we'll start getting more trailers
for beyond the spiderverse soon of course I'll do
videos for everything everyone click here to learn
how Loki season 2 is connected to spider-verse
with all the Multiverse stuff and click here
for my full breakdown of the movie with all the
Easter eggs there's so many things in this movie
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!